okay i don't
i'm gonna just assume you guys can hear
everything
south side
in which y'all [ __ ] know about girls
one time
[Music]
[Music]
over and
i don't understand what's happening over
and over again
i'm a little lost
yo when you hear talk to the south side
here talk to the team if your [ __ ]
fear pranks and respected praying for
you slow [ __ ] imma break it
down illa supreme was the businessman
and pranks was the killer remember you
used to push the bulletproof beard
i sat back and beep [ __ ]
you guys understand this i can't i can't
even a little bit
easy
had the whole projects working for 50 or
500 as a youth all i ever did was sell
fact i used to idolize okay so hussein
sold drugs as a kid
that's not something i'd recommend
in my heart to hear that [ __ ] snitched
on pat how you go out like that rumors
in the hood was just for snitching i
ain't believed that paul you helped me
okay no i've heard a lot about this you
cannot snitch
and like
i don't want to say the hood but i can't
think of anywhere else to just any other
way to describe it but snitching
is bad and all the rap songs i've
listened to
bad not a good thing
my first year
had the forerunner to see the five and
the three used to drive his truck
through the hood dragging jet skis from
general wallace to baby wise don't be
surprised how freely i thought our names
are guys
[Music]
[Music]
oh that's so clever lord forgive me for
i have sinned over and over again
oh my gosh this song is four minutes and
31 seconds what are they doing to me
again
that's a giant ass house
on top
[Music]
[Music]
was just a dose of the [ __ ] that i'm on
consider this the first chapter in the
ghetto
i know a lot of [ __ ] that get though
like bimmy and joe and princeton
righteous from hillside with the mole on
his nose throughout my struggles in the
hood i started learning life's a [ __ ]
with a pretty face what's she burning
man i'mma get cheese like chaz then with
the whips like seaguar gamble all the
time like country curly head princess
purple under pressure too they know what
they facing go against crews like vebo
and killers like pappy mason a lot of
[ __ ] i know been corrupted since birth
tights they're all nuns for fun baby
worth i know some cats to hell out
complexes like holy wall together [ __ ]
standing divided they fall around here
shook [ __ ] they keep it in motion come
around here with chiroli you can get
robbed like ocean lord okay so he's
saying do not
bring nice things around here you
will get robbed uh he's also saying that
when like
people go against each other and like
argue with each other and stuff it's not
as
[Music]
effective as if you work together
great message
tommy had lords and soul helicopters
rose voices with louis vuitton but sound
like i'm fantasizing but i'm dead
serious montana was no dummy boy
business to watch the money had money
out the ass he politic like the asians
feds couldn't catch him dirty so settle
for tax evasion forgive me
[Music]
oh no
oh dear what's going
[Music]
on over and
over again
[Music]
what they was about yo the twins was
from queens but got crazy crane without
pole throughout my time i heard tails
behind me frenchie jamaican paulie ducky
cauli rodney bumping chick [ __ ] no idea
who any of those people are
at all a lot of [ __ ] float away
outflow but ain't been in the game all
in life so don't know who i know writing
rhymes is the best way i express how i
feel if i ain't rich by 26 i'll be dead
or in jail coming up her
so he's saying if he doesn't make it by
26 years old he'll probably be in jail
or dead um
i think i'd like to say there is an
option three you could just keep trying
um
but who am i to tell you how to live i
guess confused and if you watch the news
you see players in this game they lose
i'm forgetting lefty jazz pretty tony
and lance head luke mel son trainee
money bags in a conversation over shrimp
and lobster and benny highness hurt
chico stop boxing and start a love
medina's shout out the clams and clutch
bob dre blackwell and flo don't kill you
the mad will forgive me
okay the chorus is catchy but i have a
hard time understanding most of the song
oh no
oh no
[Music]
don't do it
don't do it don't kill him don't do it
over and over
again
down
[Music]
damn
well i'm gonna give that song
a two maybe a one out of five i just
didn't like it i think it's because it's
an older song and i don't like older
music that much 2017 not that old um